in defense of the west and individualism
and everything else i thought there's no
one better that we could throw to than
jordan peterson and jordan had a bit of
an odd week because currently he is
suspended on twitter for
uh saying something about ellen or
elliot page whatever you want to call it
uh her him whatever and then which
probably just got me booted i had a good
run though you know i feel like uh
getting booted on the july 4th weekend
is sort of right um
so i want to throw to a clip of jordan
but not only did that happen that he got
suspended but he also announced a
massive partnership with the daily wire
but here's jordan on individualism and
the west
the fundamental assumptions of western
civilization are valid how about that
you know it's not
you think it's an accident oh here's how
you find out okay which countries do
people want to move away from hey not
ours which countries do people want to
move to
ours guess what they work better and
it's not because we went around the
world stealing everything we could get
our hands on it's because we got certain
fundamental assumptions right thank god
for that after thousands and thousands
of years of trying and because of that
we've managed to establish a set of
civilizations that are shining lights in
the world we actually value the
individual right the individual has
intrinsic value in western societies do
you know how long it took people to
formulate that as an idea and how
unlikely that idea is that poor you you
know useless powerless you with all your
damn faults
you're actually worth something you're
worth something to the point that the
law has to respect you
god we don't want to abandon that for
some half-witted collectivism which
we're doing as rapidly as possible
because one of the things that
characterizes the radical left types is
they don't give a damn about you as an
individual or about individuals at all
man every time i think i'm a halfway
decent broadcaster or a sort of maybe
okay guy to communicate some ideas you
just watch a little jordan and it'll put
you in your place spencer this is sort
of your specialty
i mean man he got it right there we have
turned through a lot of bad ideas a lot
of bloodshed and and a lot of pain to
get where we're at right now and we
could be on the precipice of giving it
away
sure enough well you know you talk about
those fundamental assumptions of western
civilization and you know as much as i'm
a patriot as much as i am an american
who loves his country one of the things
that makes me love the country so deeply
is that those fundamental assumptions in
the declaration represent the jewel you
know the fruit of hundreds and hundreds
of years of western striving and thought
you know the idea that all men are
created equal that they are endowed by
their creator with the inalienable
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness when the declaration says
that the you know these truths are
self-evident people think that means
that they just fall from the sky oh it's
just common sense you know everybody
thinks this but this is not true it's
not the case as peterson is pointing out
there you know this is a rare thing and
it took a long time to figure it out
good civilizations high and mighty
civilizations in the past did not
believe this sparta left babies to die
if they weren't strong enough you know
aztec human sacrifice very much a thing
and even still today you've had you've
seen people in china under the one child
policy just abandoning babies that that
were unwanted that didn't fit the needs
of the state that were economically
inconvenient the human heart man is full
of evil and to guard against that we
need these fundamental truths they're
incredibly precious and they we can
never take them for granted we have to
understand that they come as a kind of
island you know in a sea a howling
wasteland of of human darkness and to
protect that you know against the folks
who are now as you say you know bringing
up exactly the same alternatives they
present themselves as charging forth
into this bright glorious new future
they're just pagans i mean you look at
what's happening with with dobbs you
know now they're going to be states that
will you know politicians that will
stand there and advocate for babies to
be aborted like up to two weeks after
birth you know i'm i'm i'm not even
exaggerating i read articles in journals
of of medical ethics and philosophy of
science that argue for things called
something called post-birth abortion
otherwise known as infanticide and you
know you think you look at this and you
think it's some sort of shocking horror
it's not it's just the state of the
human heart without the protections that
we enshrined in our declaration and our
constitution and you know what like we
get into this defensive crouch sometimes
because they call us racist they call us
nasty and we just try to fight for the
bare minimum oh we're not racist we're
not nasty we're okay that's not enough
we're good man we're the best we're the
best that's ever been and we ought to
preserve this country because it's worth
it
not bad not bad dude you can come back
all right chris is the point is the real
point that that spencer's making there
that nothing is self-evident anymore
that the things that you're always
fighting with people about and trying to
expose at at disney or at our schools
that boys are not girls that uh there is
a difference between being racist and
non-racist all of this stuff we don't
take anything for for obvious anymore
there's nothing real anymore
yeah that's right and we shouldn't take
anything for granted you've seen it just
even with the economy in very simple
kitchen table terms
the economy doesn't run itself it's
actually an incredible accomplishment to
have clean water plentiful electricity a
large comfortable home a car or maybe
two cars in the garage these are not
natural conditions these only exist in a
very tiny sliver of human history for a
very tiny sliver of human beings and it
was all invented and sustained here and
so everything from our system of
government to our economic way of life
to our faith and traditions these things
need to be fought for and renewed and i
think in some ways what makes me
optimistic about these fights that we're
having like with mark lamont hill or
with ibrahim kendi or with uh the kind
of crazy gender people is that we're
returning to the fundamental questions
and i think if we can re-answer these
fundamental questions which we've really
not had to answer in recent years
because we've taken them for granted we
can maybe get to that point of renewing
those more fundamental pillars of our
society and so that's really the task
that we have up for us today we're not
debating about 20 versus 28 tax rates
we're not debating those technical terms
we have to go to the philosophical roots
of our situation our condition our
country and i think that we have to have
good answers just like jordan peterson
does in order to win